[Applause] well to your point hazy about the
spotlights they're still going right now in
the building and now they're turned off as we drop
the puck and our opening face off brought to you
by Theodore Robins Ford Lon had a lot of speed
going but the pass was a little behind him as
he entered the Zone kept alive though out High by
minakov Johnston comes in along the corner boards
trying to work it free and he does carrot scores
Sam carrot and Anaheim has the first [Applause]
goal I'm on the board look at the how they are
stacked up against those fors win a puck battle
nice little dish there from Brett Leon
and Carrick wastes no time just inside
the face off dot where does he put this he
elevates it over the right shoulder of the
goenda binan has it taken away from him inside
the line by Dale who shook off the little shove
and now speed through the neutral zone fower
drops it off Dale over on the wing and the
scores speed on the entry and a quick shot
it's two to [Music] nothing well this is a
gift putting the puck on the net good Rush up the
ice the combination of Dale and Fowler just DP
the puck over to vrono and that's one the goes
right underneath the right pad of ronto who's
caught halfway he's not up he's not down he's
caught in the middle 125 games in his last six
seasons as the Ducks win the draw and he turns
stro away once and the rebound flutters just
wide stro has it again that was off a Faceoff
win for Anaheim in the offensive zone Mavis
trying to protect the puck out High left
it on the blue line and now Anaheim with
numbers down low lome sets it up and M
with the finish the first NHL goal for pav
mitov well watch the zip he puts on this
backhand pass there's lome it's the give
and go now he breaks into the middle gets
it back slides it across it's an empty nit
for pavle mikov Ryan stro nice little dish
boy that backand pass was a thing of beauty
talk about your Milestone go goals first NHL
goal for pav mikov Ducks failed to get it out
however and now Cami finds NES once more his
pass across again not in the Wheelhouse so
they'll feed it back around Nas off the side
of the goal with a one-time the doall tips to
the corner a double Miner for high sticking
so this could be a critical juncture in the
game as Anaheim looks to hang on to the lead
upended as the penalty has expired Anaheim now
0 for two on the power play and D to spell down
creates a two onone AO hands it off great save
G and he's going to the Anaheim locker room right
now Burns settles it back in his own Zone it's
clear broken up zis great pass to Terry down
low walks it into the blue paint and Ron sits
on it whenever they get the puck of the neutral
zone it's like they don't have a lot of time to
make a decision Brady Shay keeps in and NES from
behind the net moves it back right Point peshi
lets it Go just wide came off the boards and
Shay tried to steer it on that it went right
to terrain and he scores that's a bounce the
canes get one and T table ter now with goals
in each of the first three games this season in
Period number two and we really have they just
kept shoveling pcks towards the front of the de
so sure that may have gone off touch Fowler and
just kind of ramp up I think it does I think it
goes off the shaft of the stick and up into the
top Corner in perod number two and we really have
they just kept shoving pucks towards the front of
the net I'm so sure that may have gone off touch
fouler and just kind of ramp up I think it does
I think it goes off the shaft of the stick and up
into the top Corner three and 1 half to go second
period this one through the neutral
zone and Tracked Down by stro patrono
in the corner stro got it in front
score FR patrono second of the
[Applause] [Music] night rice Rome hunts a puck
down there I watch this play my pck Mavish he
wins a little puck battle keeps it alive
got some good support from Ryan stro and
he's just going to pop it to fonto and so
we know what a good release Frank patrono
has the Ron actually moved out of the
net coming in off left wing was Martin
hook Burns at Center on the regroup
snaps it across Jacob slaven off
the inside of the post We Begin
the third period five on [Music]
five and the ducks with a 4-1 lead and is batted
away another play by Bo Gru yeah Bo Gru can win
face offs he's an excellent defensive forward
he's earned a spot on this team and and he's
going to play a pivotal role in the penalty kill
this year boff carries it back in in the dying
seconds and a one time Blast by terrain off the
post and in Jackson lome was in the vicinity here
and he may have distracted him a little bit
because you could see he was late to react to
the shot and it's high blocker I think lacole
just at the moment that the shot was released
was just passing in in front of Lucas doy it's
a it's a puck that's upes at the line feeds it
across mov great pass and vrono just fumbled
it otherwise he might have had a hattick little
hot I I don't think the pass was sitting flat
Anaheim with their best pressure of the period
Le and F rebound and Fallen to his right Bronto
keeps it out still loose in the blue paint and
he gets the whistle a dangerous attempt there by
Sebastian AO boy he was down below the top of the
circles NIS winds it up right through the logo
and into the Zone over for bunting on left wing
he's got room got it across and NIS redirects it
home it's a bad penalty for Trevor zigris to take
with a TW goal lead and 5 minutes to go in the
period And it costs the Ducks a goal beautiful
feed by Michael bunting NIS with a give and go he
just drives far post and Bunting was able to just
kind of thread the needle there and it's it's a
tap in no chance for doal so the last four and
a half gets a little dicey for the Ducks as now
it's 43 Long bid by Burns block by Fowler Burns
keeps it moving around the boards empty net at
the other end six attackers for Carolina KMI pin
to the boards loose Puck the Fowler he'll take a
bit at the empty net and he scores from about 170
ft and this is center cut here's the block I was
talking about off the left ankle and you can see
he's he's laboring just a little bit but he gets
back to the front of the net and he looked like a
different guy when that puck squirted free to him
and this is right in the middle great finish for
Cam Fowler he gets rewarded Troy ter pulled the
puck off the boards and got it to him NIS able to
keep it knocked it out of midair turns back for
orlock across with Burns they'll switch sides
so they can let a one- timer go here it is from
morof block goodus I think got a piece of it and
Mavish pulls it off the boards moves it on left
wing and here's the hat trick for patrono way has
been very very good strove vono and aage tonight
the first player in the 30-year history of this
franchise to have a hattick in the home
opener Frank patrono Gus gets in the way
of Jarvis's pass and that's going to
do it the win streak in home openers
reaches eight straight and Greg Cronin
has his first win as an NHL head coach